hello everyone my name is researcher
Miller and the SCP were going to be
looking at today is SCP 817 object class
Euclid special containment procedures as
CP 817 is held in a solitary confinement
cell insightful numerous mechanisms for
incapacitating SCP 817 are to be built
into its cell including sedative loaded
darts pumps to fill the chamber with
sleeping gas pumps to remove oxygen from
the chamber a mechanism to flood the
chamber with water or acidic alkaline
solutions an electric current that can
be run through the floor and walls a
mechanism to fill the entire room with
quick-hardening foam and a mechanism to
introduce approximately 300 black flies
to the room SCP 817 has a known phobia
of flying insects the remainder of
scp-871 its current abilities the
following procedures must be
re-evaluated and revised every time SCP
817 undergoes a metamorphic shift
SCP 817 s containment chamber is
currently a simple padded confinement
cell apart from the measures mentioned
above air conditioned 18 degrees Celsius
SCP 817 is fet kilograms of cooked meat
daily as in its current form it consumes
calories very rapidly a detachment of
least five armed security personnel must
be present whenever SCP 817 is released
from its cell restraints must be placed
on its wing structures and a
specifically designed muzzle on its head
and neck description SCP 817 is a
humanoid of intermediate gender and
variable physical features although
genetic testing suggests it was what a
young asian male SCP 817 periodically
undergoes radical metamorphic changes to
its physiology the delay between
metamorphic events varies but it is
usually about two to three months these
shifts and the physiological
abnormalities produced caused SCP 817
enormous pain however it seems to suffer
no actual damage to its body systems
additionally SCP 817 seems to be
incapable of deliberately injuring
itself SCP 817 is mentally unstable
displaying severe psychotic symptoms
during psychotic episodes which make up
roughly 30% of its waking hours and are
always triggered by its metamorphic
shift SCP 817 is extremely hostile and
will attempt to breach containment and
attack personnel in its current form SCP
817 is one and a half metres tall lacks
primary or secondary sex organs and in
place of arms has limbs resembling wings
of a bat that fold around its torso and
span three meters when fully extended
bones and muscle are composed of unknown
polymers unrelated to any naturally
occurring skeletal or muscular material
and percent lighter than their baseline
human counterparts because of this
reduction in its mass to force exerted
ratio as CP 817 is fully capable of
extended unassisted flight using its
wings
although doing so requires an enormous
amount of energy expenditure it's
extremely high metabolic rate keeps SCP
817 s body temperature at a constant
degrees Celsius and that appears to be
suffering the appropriate degree of pain
for a human heated to such a temperature
despite a lack of actual harm to its
physiology additionally while SCP 817 s
current neck and jaw structures appear
humanoid it has demonstrated the ability
to suddenly jerk its neck forward and
unfold its jaw presumably as a feeding
mechanism in lieu of arms
addendum notable past metamorphic forms
of scp-871 tall and thin with a
reflective index of nearly zero required
no sustenance beyond solar radiation
efficiency of absorption estimated at
percent vastly greater than any known
biological or artificial method had no
orifices whatsoever
sensory excretory digestive or
reproductive attempts to create solar
panels based on its skin proved
fruitless number two female in
appearance exude from its pores
see attached image tranquilizers
sleeping gas and oxygen removal proved
ineffective successfully incapacitated
by electric shock drainage added to
containment chamber to counter the
corrosive effects kept sedated and on an
IV feed for the duration of this form
natural feeding methods seem to involve
injecting truth has fully dissolved
followed by direct absorption of
nutrients through the skin
suffered the same level of pain that
constant exposure to what caused in the
normal human number three translucent
and able to phase effortlessly through
objects tranquilizers failed sleeping
gas failed successfully incapacitated by
oxygen removal spent most of its time in
this form attempting to scream and two
days in began attempting to claw its own
eyes out emitted a very small but
measurable amount of gamma radiation all
attempts at study fail
and finally number four two and a half
meters tall with thick bulky musculature
breached containment killing and
consuming personnel before dr.
incapacitated at accidentally by
releasing a swarm of flies intended to
feed musculature proved to be a complex
and powerful hydraulic system powered by
ten large hearts in its core pumping an
unusual I core three additional hearts
powered a second circulatory system
which served to provide the other hearts
with oxygen any pressure applied to its
skin caused significant pain including
contact with the ground
addendum an analysis by dr. indicates
even at the most conservative estimate
SCP 817 has expended less than 10% of
the energy it is taken since in
containment its method of energy storage
is presently unknown dr. hypothesizes
and has recommended that SCP 817 rations
be cut to significantly below the
current estimated starvation level
recommendation still pending review this
concludes our lecture today thank you
all for listening and you are all
dismissed goodbye
I would like to give a special thank you
to Andre bishop desmond Hoskins and gaza
berry thank you all very much for your
support
it's greatly appreciated if you would
like a special thank you at the end of
each of my videos and some other cool
stuff as well go to patreon.com/scishow
[Music]
you